ja willkommen zu einer neuen Serie von
filocast diesmal wieder mit Marcel
urnschall meinem Experten für die neuen
Medien wir hatten kürzlich ein Interview
geführt zum Thema Bitcoin Philosophie
des Bitcoins da mache ich auch oben
rechts einen Link rein zu dieser Sendung
heute geht es um das wetterversum und
konkret um die Frage wird unsere
Gesellschaft besser durch das Metaversum
im Metaversum hallo Marcel schön dass du
da bist vielleicht sollten wir wenn wir
die Frage diskutieren wollen erstmal
klären was ist eigentlich das Metaversum
das ist ja ein Begriff der ist jetzt
total im Trend total in der Mode und
deswegen finde ich sollten auch
PhilosophInnen und Philosophen sich
damit mal befassen warum sollten wir das
immer den Technokraten überlassen das
heißt wir sind da auch gefragt was
würdest du sagen wie könnte man das
Metaversum so ganz kurz und knackig
definieren ich habe auch ein paar Ideen
aber fang doch du mal an ja danke nee
klassischerweise sieht man ja stellt man
sich gerade in unserer heutigen Zeit
durch dieses Video von Facebook auch die
sich ja zu Meter umbenannt haben stellt
man sich beim Universum so eine
immersive 3D Welt vor die man eintaucht
vielleicht mit irgendeiner Brille ist im
Oculus oder dergleichen und die Frage
ist hier aber so ist es wirklich so und
und was wird da drin gemacht also
Metaversum kann durchaus dreidimensional
sein aber die Frage ist dann ist es eine
virtuelle Realität also we are in dem
Oculus oder hat man eine Augmented
Reality das heißt wir gehen durch die
Straßen und sehen halt immer noch durch
eine Brille alles was wir sehen aber on
top noch irgendwie andere digitale
Erscheinungen und die das ist so ein
bisschen die mediale Frage also wie
schaut das aus
die andere Frage oder die andere der
andere Aspekt der Qualität bei einer
Definition von Metaversum wäre halt was
macht man da überhaupt und und ich
dachte ich ich komme auch von der
Spielewelt den spielbegeistert und und
die Frage ist so naja gut wir haben ja
irgendwie schon die ganze Zeit 3D Spiele
und die sind auch egalisiert und Leute
haben sich da in diesen unendlichen
Welten auch schon verloren also es gibt
Menschen die haben sozusagen die
diszipieren ist mit diversen schon
erlebt in irgendeiner Form ja
Unterschied wäre dann okay der
Spielebereich nur der Spielebereich
würde nicht ausreichen um das zu
beschreiben was wir da sagen wollen das
heißt vielleicht ist da noch was anderes
drin und und und meine Vermutung geht es
in Richtung Arbeit und Ökonomie also das
Geld eben eine Rolle spielt das sagst du
glaube ich sehr richtig also es gibt
schon so Vorform des metaphersums online
multiplayer spiele World of Warcraft du
sagst völlig richtig da können wir uns
verlieren da können wir die halbe Zeit
unseres mit verbringen da drin das haben
wir auch viele gemacht viele haben es
auch bereut danach jetzt ist die Frage
was ist das was ist das neue das
metaversums Gegenüber Multiplayer
spielen ich glaube du hast ein ganz
wichtigen Aspekt genannt nämlich das
arbeiten alle der Alltag nicht nur
irgendwie Freizeit gut viele spielen
auch Computerspiele professionell diese
professionellen Gamerinnen und Gamer die
gibt es auch ist ein neues Phänomen aber
ich würde mal sagen das Metaversum ins
Lebenswelt dich noch breiter und
betrifft wirklich jeden von uns da
müssen wir nicht gamerin oder Gamer sein
damit es uns anspricht und vielleicht
können wir da ein bisschen dran ansetzen
all das Metaversum scheint eine neue
Existenzform zu sein eine neue
alltagsform in der wir nicht nur Medien
konsumieren wie man sehr häufig sich
vorstellt wenn man die neuen Medien hört
wir lassen es berieseln von Netflix
Serien und so weiter so eine Metaversum
da werden wir selbst aktiv da können wir
selbst etwas tun mein Vorschlag wäre
deswegen
das Metaversum als ein virtuellen
Handlungsraum zu bestimmen Handlungsraum
bedeutet wir können dort spielen wir
können dort simulieren wir können daran
aber auch interagieren wir können darin
auch arbeiten und Geld verdienen was
hältst du von diesem Vorschlag virtuelle
Handlungsraum ja der gefällt mir sehr
gut
vor allem
weil dann auch
sich ethische Fragen
was können das ausgehen dass wir Akteure
sind in diesem digitalen space und zwar
Akteure die zur Verantwortung gezogen
werden können
das Spannende ist aber gleichzeitig dass
wir gar nicht wissen was ist wie
verhalten sich ethisch also wie
verhalten sich sozusagen moralische
Handlungsräume im meterversum erst eben
da wieder das Spiele Beispiel wir können
irgendwie es gibt Spiele Ego-Shooter die
bestehen in sich nur da da also wie
diesen dadurch definiert dass man Leute
tötet das ist Inhalt der Inhalt des
Spiels und da wäre das Böse Handeln
nicht dass Menschen umbringen im Spiel
also die Charaktere sondern das Böse
handeln wäre wenn man sich irgendwie
schneller macht oder so und cheatet und
dann auf einmal besseres Spiel gewinnt
und die Frage ist jetzt also
ich kann mir gerade noch keine Welt
vorstellen in dieser also der nächste
Schritt den wir da vielleicht gehen wo
wo Leute also wo man den 3D Charakter
tötet und es war schlecht ist also
irgendwie ja ich kann mir das nicht
vorstellen es müsste irgendwie es wäre
erst dann schlimm wenn auch unsere
physische Existenz darunter leiden würde
unter diesem Akt das heißt diese
ethische Fragen die die öffnen sich da
total und und und und da ja finde ich
einfach spannend ich habe noch einen
Punkt aber vielleicht kannst du noch
kurz dazu was sagen ich finde es total
wichtig dass du diese diese moralischen
Fragen ansprichst also wenn wir sagen
das Metaversum ist ein Handlungsraum
dann stellt sie die Frage nach der
Zurechenbarkeit oder auch erstmal nach
der Frage was ist überhaupt eine
Handlung wir hatten jetzt schon auf
Computerspiele hingewiesen da mache ich
auch oben rechts einen Link einzelne
Sendung über Computerspiele und
Philosophie wir haben gesehen den
Computerspielen ist ziemlich viel
Simulation wir töten ja nicht wirklich
andere Menschen sondern wir simulieren
die Tötung an anderen Personen und das
Böse wie Du richtig sag dieses
unmoralische Kämme dann ins Spiel wenn
wir im Spiel sozusagen die Spielregeln
brechen oder verletzen also wenn wir
cheaten wenn wir Aimbots benutzen wenn
wir vielleicht sogar dafür sorgen dass
andere Konkurrentinnen und Konkurrentin
gehindert werden dass wir ihn
irgendwelche Viren noch auf den Computer
einspielen um dadurch irgendwie Vorteile
zu haben jetzt stellt sich ja die Frage
wie sieht das aus wenn mir wirklich
interagieren zum Beispiel auch Arbeiten
ich würde hier vorschlagen auch erstmal
die Frage zu diskutieren wie wir
überhaupt im Metaversum existieren du
hattest schon gesagt wir existieren ja
nicht körperlich also nicht leiblich
körperlich wir sind ja irgendwie
virtuell dort Existenz existent und da
wäre ein Punkt von mir den man
diskutieren könnte das Thema Avatare
also du würdest das sicherlich auch
sagen der Reiz des metaversums besteht
darin dass wir uns neue Identitäten
zulegen können also das hat wieder sehr
viele Ähnlichkeiten mit dem
Computerspiel da können wir auch Avatare
verwenden aber mir scheint eben auch im
Metaversum jetzt zumindest in der
Version die da Meta oder jemals Facebook
jetzt propagiert diese dieses Avatar die
Avatar Idee sehr prominent zu sein ja
toll also
die Freiräume die dadurch entstehen sind
glaube ich sehr attraktiv und man sieht
ja auch jetzt schon in der Social Media
Web 2.0 Welt wie attraktiv und beliebtes
ist dass man sich irgendein Profilbild
von irgendeinem Lieblingstag da auch mal
zulegt für mich war es eigentlich eher
eine Besonderheit muss ich sagen auch
wenn ich dann noch relativ jung war zum
Teenager was für mich eine Besonderheit
das Facebook irgendwie
echte Fotos von einem will als
Profilbild und das wurde immer so
suggeriert der echte Name das ist echt
ein Foto und und das hat so noch mal
natürlich echter gemacht irgendwo aber
es hat auch eine Komponente rausgenommen
die eigentlich sehr früh schon existiert
hat und dass diese Spielfreude und
Freiheit in ich bin der der ich sein
möchte und die war aber auch schon da in
social genau die die waren auch schon da
in Social Media und und und und und und
und und und und das ist halt natürlich
jetzt die Frage also
ich glaube nicht dass metavers das ist
wieder versum oder ist
was komplett Neues ist das ist eben naja
wir haben viele Aspekte eh schon im Web
2.0 erlebt und den Spielewelten erlebt
und jetzt scheint er sich so Sachen zu
mischen und zoomen oder auch so ein
Video call wie wir ihn machen das sind
dann vielleicht Dinge die dort immer sie
war ablaufen also einnehmender ja also
ich würde da zustimmen also so viel ist
da nicht neue Metaversum die
Technologien gibt schon
größtenteils die Phänomene gibt schon
bei Computerspielen aber was vielleicht
wirklich Neues ist diese lebensweltliche
perversive also sich wirklich in alle
Bereiche ausdehnende virtuelle Welt das
eben auch unser Arbeiten unser Alltag
vielleicht auch sonstige alltägliche
Dinge virtualisiert werden können und
dass wir uns eben nicht nur im
spielerischen sondern eben auch im
anderen Hinsichten mit anderen Leuten
vernetzen können gut das können wir auch
jetzt schon eigentlich im Internet das
Internet ist ja diese Grundstruktur die
überhaupt diese ganzen Interaktion erste
möglich aber kann sich das vielleicht
als eine intelligente Fortführung
bisherige Ansätze vorstellen die einfach
in alle Lebensbereiche vordringt eben
auch gerade ins arbeiten und sonstige
Handlungen die nicht nur Simulationen
oder Fiktionen sind wie bei
Computerspielen voll und und mir fällt
gerade nur ein so also hypothetisch
könnten auch wir haben ja dieses
Internet of things also Küchengeräte
oder ähnliches in denen dort vielleicht
auch
eben diese Aspekte aus dem Alltag also
wir neigen dazu Arbeit und Alter
gleichzusetzen es gibt ja noch den
Alltag ohne Arbeit also die auch noch
nicht digitalisiert wurden und es werden
zum Beispiel Küchen in der Küche
irgendwie zu kochen oder Geräte und da
kann ich mir irgendwie vorstellen dass
vielleicht da auch Schnittpunkte
irgendwann entstehen wo man wo wo die
Geräte connected sind zu diesem
meta-works und
eine Rolle spielen die spielen auch im
Metapher ist eine Rolle sowie in echt in
echt erfüllen sie die Funktion die wir
haben aber metamorus könnte sowas sein
aber auch das können wir jetzt schon
machen auch ohne metavers es könnte sein
dass man die zum Internet verbindet und
sagt naja je nachdem wie man das Gerät
benutzt zum Beispiel den Kühlschrank
werden die Aktivitäten getrackt Daten
gesammelt und dann kriegt man irgendwie
ein Rabatt oder Bonus Gutscheine was
auch immer und das geht natürlich sehr
nah auch wieder an diese datenökonomie
die Facebook fährt und da öffnen sich
auch riesige Räume auf einmal durchs
meet the worst die auch nicht unbedingt
schön sein müssen
ja erst zum wichtigen Punkt angesprochen
Thema Datenschutz Thema
Datenauswertung
das sollten wir vielleicht auch noch
thematisieren problematisieren das
metavers wie es jetzt meistens
propagiert wird ist die Erfindung einer
ja ökonomischen
Einheit eines
Unternehmens eines riesigen Unternehmens
wie stehst Du aus ethischer Sicht dazu
sollte man hier nicht ein bisschen
warnen und auch aus philosophischer
Sicht darauf blicken sagen wollen wir
wirklich
Versuchsobjekte Datenobjekte eines
großen Unternehmens werden wenn wir uns
im Metaversum herumtreiben wollen sollte
das wirklich ökonomisch interessiert
sein oder sollte nicht viel mehr die
eigentliche Idee des metaversums sein
jegliche Aktivitäten ohne dieses
ökonomische Interesse durchführen zu
können ja und und da also da stellt sich
für mich eigentlich wieder die
Definitionsfrage so in den Vordergrund
weil es für mich nicht so schlecht ist
zu sehen das eine Mal möchten wir also
wenn wir vom Datenschutz kommen und
sagen naja also sowas ist irgendwie
nicht gut wenn unsere unser Verhalten im
Metaversum getrackt wird was fluffig ist
aufgrund unserer Technologie ist es
relativ einfach die Daten zu tracken die
werden getrackt und dann verkauft und da
passiert ja eine Verschmelzung von
Realität und Virtualität die wir ja
immer so nach vorne schieben und sagen
das ist jetzt das Metaversum diese
Verschmelzung ist das ist doch irgendwie
auf einmal ist es eins und das ich frage
mich so in welchen Bereichen ist das
denn cool oder erwünscht sozusagen
und da komme ich wieder auf diesen Punkt
zu naja ist mieterversum eher aus
spielesicht vielleicht nicht das tolle
in diesem Konzept des Spiels dass das
eigentlich das erwünschte Metaversum ist
und die Arbeit halt vielleicht dann doch
eher tendenziell analoger oder getrennt
sein stattfinden sollte und jetzt kommen
wir auch die den naja vielleicht und das
ist das tolle ein digitalen Welten sie
können parallel existieren vielleicht
gibt's halt eben auch
abgeschottete Bereiche die nur für die
Arbeit gedacht sind und abgestattete
Bereiche die für
das Spiel gedacht sind und also
richtiger Punkt ja also ich glaube
allerdings habe ich ein bisschen leicht
andere Auffassung ich glaube die
Bereiche verschmelzen immer mehr
miteinander also ich glaube man kann die
metaverso nicht mehr so sinnvoll
unterscheiden zwischen Spiel und Arbeit
sondern wir sehen ja auch Gamification
Momente Einzug halten in verschiedene
alltägliche Arbeitspraktiken und ein
weiterer Punkt den man vielleicht noch
behandeln sollte ist es geht hier auch
immer um Fiktion also Fiktion heißt ich
kann Dinge machen die ich vielleicht
sonst in der physischen Welt im
physischen Alltag nicht tun kann ich
kann ein neues Aussehen geben ich kann
eine besondere Rolle einnehmen das heißt
hier wird auch unsere Kreativität unsere
Freiheit extrem erweitert im metavers
und alle sollten wir nicht unterschätzen
das hat natürlich immer was mit
Spielerei auch zu tun wir spielen wie
erproben neue Grenzen aber ihr könnt
darin eben auch neue Realitäten erzeugen
virtuelle Realitäten
ja und und auch ein Beispiel ist ja x
Infinity zum Beispiel das ist ein
blockchain Projekt was es ziemlich weit
nach oben geschafft hat mit der
einfachen Idee dass Leute durch das
Spielen eines Online-Games auf dem Handy
oder Laptop
rewards bekommen also coins in Form von
diesen Token der von diesem blockchain
krypto-projekt ausgegeben wird und der
hat halt der ist dann gelistet auf
Krypto Börsen und den kann man verkaufen
für echtes Geld und anscheinend war es
halt so dass in den auf den Philippinen
Leute teilweise da hat sich dann mehr
gelohnt dieses Spiel zu spielen ist
tatsächlich Arbeit zu leisten wo genau
diese Verschmelzung auch stattfindet
irgendwie und und da merke ich aber auch
wieder es ist auch interessant dass wir
eigentlich diese verschmelzenden Aspekte
wir sind schon mittendrin das Social
Media irgendwie politische Landschaften
prägen mit dem was da drin diskutiert
wird ist einfach ein riesiger Beweis
dafür dass
digitales und
physisches
schon längst verschmelzt sind deshalb
deswegen ist wichtige wichtige Einsicht
wir sollten die nicht so getrennt sehen
dass
digitale und das physische sondern es
gibt immer Mischformen immer
ergänzungsformen
Interferenzen und das ist ja auch das
was mit Augmented Reality gemeint ist
häufig wir sollten Sie nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen diese zwei
Welten das ist sicherlich sehr
gefährlich sondern wir sollten eher
schauen wie hängen sie im Alltag auf
eine fruchtbare konstruktive Weise
miteinander zusammen da sehe ich auch
für die Philosophie noch ganz viele
Aufgaben jetzt zum Schluss unseres
Interviews Marcel die Eingangsfrage noch
mal wir bekommen eine bessere
Gesellschaft durch das Metaversum oder
bekommen eine schlechtere Gesellschaft
was meinst du
also ich habe etwas Angst vor der
Version das metaversums wo man wo man wo
alles getrackt wird und erarbeiten nur
noch digitalisiert wird und man
tatsächlich
über die Screen time die man eh schon
hinaus hat noch mehr Screen time hat ich
kann mir gerade nicht vorstellen wie
also welche Technologie ohne Screen time
1 m versum erzeugen könnte das wäre
vielleicht eine Lösung weiß nicht mit
mit Lichtprojektion oder sowas wo also
dieses vom Bildschirm eingeschlossen in
dem Zimmer sein und da aber dann
gedanklich in andere Welt auch und davon
habe ich etwas Angst weil wir das eh
schon machen das nicht so gesund ist in
meinen Augen und positiv sehe ich aber
tatsächlich
dass das man wirklich um also die
Vorstellungskraft und Kreativität auf
den nächstes Level bringen kann mit AI
mit blockchain Sachen live auf einmal
ineinander wie auf einer Art und Weise
niemals zuvor der Fall war wir können
auf einmal Bilder einfach erzeugen mit
wenn wir eine Idee haben ich habe ja
neulich eben
eine eigene nutzt und einfachen Text
geschrieben über ein Bild was ich mir
vorgestellt habe und habe dann das am
ersten passende Bild von der generiert
habe ich genommen und eben weiter heraus
zu sein gefiltert bis ich sage so hey
das ist ein tolles Bild so das habe ich
war ja das bringst du jetzt recht an ja
ich denke das ist ein wichtiger Punkt
dass du noch erwähnst dass wir nicht nur
als menschliche Subjekte darin
interagieren sondern es gibt
Küchengeräte es gibt den Fernseher es
gibt künstliche Intelligenz und wir
geraden deine ganz ganz spannende Mensch
Maschine Interaktion die uns ganz neue
Möglichkeiten eröffnet und ich schließe
mich eigentlich dann im Fazit an als ich
denke man kann diese Frage wird jetzt
unsere Gesellschaft besser oder
schlechter im oder durchs Wetter werden
nicht so einfach beantworten was ich
ganz wichtig finde ist dass die
ökonomischen Interessen zurücktreten
dass man das wirklich Open Access macht
im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes open das
aber auch diejenigen die im Metaversum
dann drin sind dass die auch mit dazu
beitragen dieses Metaversum aufrecht zu
erhalten also damit die müssen irgendwie
beteiligt werden auf eine Fähre
demokratische Art und Weise nämlich
letzte Hinsicht könnten daraus natürlich
auch globale Phänomene werden so eine
Weltgesellschaft einen virtuelles
Weltbürgertum was wirklich alle gleichen
Rechte hat Meinungsfreiheit diese Rechte
die sie Menschen in manchen Staaten eben
nicht haben auf physische Weise dass man
dienen auf digitale Weise gibt das wenn
eine ganz tolle Entwicklung und so
konnte das dann auch rückwirkend auf
diese jeweiligen Gesellschaft und die
physischen Gesellschaft und diese
Gesellschaften verändern also sowas
praktisch als eine ideale Gesellschaft
könnte man auch versuchen aus
philosophischer Sicht das Metaversum zu
konzipieren ist natürlich eine ein Ideal
aber warum nicht ne dazu sehen
ja und und Leute können
typische ausüben die sie davon nicht
Geld ausüben konnten also man kann
Architekt werden auf einmal weil
Gravitation vielleicht bei Gebäuden im
meterversum keine Rolle spielt naja
der gelten andere Regeln das sind die
virtuellen Gesetze die nicht mehr den
physischen Gesetzen folgen auch aus
Zeitraum Logik eine ganz andere
raumlogik haben wir da auch da könnte
man auch nochmal groß weiter
philosophieren ich denke für heute
genügt es Marcel vielen Dank für deine
Bereitschaft hier auf filocast ja und
Antwort zu stehen zu diesem zentralen
Thema ich freue mich überlegen uns noch
weitere Themen gerne auch unten in den
Kommentaren dann Wünsche äußern Marcel
und ich haben uns überlegt mal eine
Sendung noch über blockchain zu machen
Marcel du hast das Thema mal
angesprochen immer wieder es ist so eine
Grundstruktur die auch die ganze
digitale Welt irgendwie zusammenhält und
die auch wirklich viele Leute noch gar
nicht richtig kennen und ich glaube
darüber sollten wir auch mal demnächst
wieder eine Sendung machen
auf jeden Fall ich freue mich drauf und
bis nächstes Mal ja vielen Dank tschüss